well well our war hero has arrived
killers in the flower moon was a series
of murders of Osage men and women to
Bilk them at the discovery of oil on
their land the Osage reign of terrible
is a fascinating piece of American
History I was drawn to the idea to tell
this terribly tragic story that was
never brought to national attention
Marty obsessed with telling the story
but the most honesty that he possibly
could one of the key things was that it
was drawn to this world friendship and
love existed with blatant extortion
exploitation and murder
when this money started coming we should
have known it came with something else
the film Earnest develops a relationship
with Molly Burkhart I don't know what
she said but must have been Indian for
handsome devil Ernest was encouraged to
marry her by his Uncle Bill Hale in
order to get her family shares in the
oil profits Hale was a very enigmatic
presence in Osage country he definitely
represented somebody that wanted to take
advantage of the situation at all costs
their time is open
there was a need to tell this story from
Martin Scorsese there was something
intrinsic in him to do this story
Justice there's a Sinister nature of the
murders of the Osage people back in
America to make all this go away you
know they don't happen anymore I wanted
to do justice to the Osage
so that the audience feels the immensity
of the tragedy
foreign